sachez que comme vous venez d'un télé
crochet ce soir on va cueillir les
chroniqueurs ils sont tous en télé
crochet dans des membres de télé crochet
on va accueillir d'abord un groupe qui a
fait qui a été formée grâce à la
première saison de popstars c'était quoi
le groupe première saison ouais c'est
elle elle a exactement les l5
elles sont avec nous ce soir
applaudissements fournis
[Applaudissements]
je suis un gars
merde
merci il faut pas rester là madame merci
merci madame s'est passé par là s'est
excusé moi oui c'est pour lire dans les
lignes de la main je n'ai rien merci
allez-vous mettre là bas mais fait ça
répète je n'avais pas marqué vous en
fous je suis très inquiet non
franchement je suis très inquiet au
sujet est-ce qu'on peut remettre la
chanson ce que pouvaient refaire votre
dans sa marque orange
[Musique]
alors je vais vous dire quelque chose
que je vous aime beaucoup
oui à la votre place merci rendez moi je
sais faire ça quand même à un bon
mais c'est pas possible mais sans lui
mais qui m'a fait une bande de bras
cassés pareil ça vous a plu crise 1
c'était super heureusement la cgt louisy
joseph et ça c'est beau oui oui oui
cette louisy joseph ami jacques luisi où
c'est cela qui partait caisse et d'un
gain dé vous faites un truc c'est une
virilité incroyable non mais faut il
reflète le assis par terre et ceux ci a
legacy ouais mais bon franchement il est
bon et vous aussi ça nous va très bien
comme ça on brûle vita
non je trouve ça laid mercy west très
joli hameau si j'aime bien heureuse ça
nous va hyper bien vous vous besoin
jean vila plus j'ai très vite envie
d'appeler la police ans non mais
vraiment très longtemps à me déguiser un
oui bah oui bah non mais ça s'ouvre et
vous faites n'est pas bougé le bixi vous
avez fait ça on a les pattes d'eph
ah ouais d'accord des petits corps c'est
comme ça d'accord merci vous fait vous
êtes habillé quoi merci
il a remporté la saison 5 de la nouvelle
star c'est qu'ils saison 5 de la
nouvelle star la nouvelle bien dorées
julien doré qu'il est fort il est avec
nous ce soir je l'adoré
[Applaudissements]
mais il ya plus
c'est moi
m
[Applaudissements]
à
mathieu génial vois franchement c'est
pas mal je reconnais que la perruque est
très bien il a un peu le même visage
oui le souci des détails regarder la
barrette
outre la centrale émergents
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon c'est bon merci allez on les a
connus dans popstars saison 3 les lilas
dans ce groupe on appelait les link up
oui aller il y avait match om foucault
bien sûr mais juste avant on va d'abord
accueillir donc les link up parce qu'ils
sont trois rappelé que la chanson
violèrent team ekoi lionel tim est faux
de croire
[Applaudissements]
m
heures du soir mais kg
mais
et moi et moi ya le regard du siècle et
wesh wesh désastre catastrophe dans ce
groupe n'a ni queue ni tête
l'entité wesh wesh alors résumé donc
c'est lionel tim wynn classic où vous
êtes autisme on dirait sur you know dira
mais qu'un persiste à l'alpe d'huez dans
le turf est en effet la fia d sur 100 m
hier sur bxl ça c est mon corps à
sorgues laisser m pokora ont tenu à ses
macbook à sa thèse commerciaux
[Musique]
mon étoile polaire
[Applaudissements]
pouvoir
j'adore
j'adore quand il ne me demande d'où je
viens mais aussi 6 4 et sur mon chemin
oh là là je vous le dis ça fait partie
de mon top 5 de mes chansons préférées
de ma vie entière
non je suis comme un ouf sur cette
chanson c'est une des chansons préférées
aussi de celui qui va camper ce
personnage c'est ma cousine en fait ils
chantent oui c'est sheryfa luna est avec
nous ce soir
regardez jean michel maire il est
magnifique
je n'avais pas
[Musique]
vie
en quelle année chez rita de nike
habillé comme ça parce que là je ne
comprends pas je rêvais ya quinze jours
c'était un peu comme ça alors juste et
maintenant de venir vous êtes passés au
minibar à jamais bah ouais alors je fais
moi dans la bouche
soufflez vous saurez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle tord studio cm de l'enceinte
ouais il est passé à 213 cm d'être beau
dossier merci en tout cas serrée même
doucement c'est un bel hommage
ouais tu mets de la wes est pas